Vincent: Hi, Guys Glad to see you back from Spring Break.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah. I just came back from North Carolina yesterday. I got depressed again, coming back to Pittsburgh.
Yooni Choi: Me, too. I missed staying in the pools of Cancun.
Vincent: Good. Let's start all we doing. Stand up meetings. We have a mentor meeting coming up next week, and I think it will be great for us to build our work. stay and make progress before meeting with them next week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yes, so far, I think Uni has done a great job in only investigating different cloud services as our efficiency. But action, items, and agenda items are still on clear to us.
Yooni Choi: I agree there are many Nlp services that we can explore to achieve this task. Have you guys heard about the chat gpt from open AI? I think it would be a great Canada for this task.
Vincent: Yeah, it's amazing. I've been using it extensively from all my at the project. I knew nothing about that. But I keep me at all the great examples about park operation
Vincent: for next week. Wington's action item will be Mass. H. I. D's Apis for extracting agenda and action items from the Meeting Transcript.
Jeffrey Feng: Thank you, Dr. I believe Chat Gbt will definitely help us a lot in this project.
Jeffrey Feng: Okay, moving on to our next session item. Have you guys
Jeffrey Feng: decide what documents we should submit for the next week?
Yooni Choi: Yeah, let me take a quick look at canvas. Okay, we have a plan and design document you next week. Most of this stuff seems to overlap a lot with our previous documents.
Jeffrey Feng: Yes.
Jeffrey Feng: for the planned document. We have introduction, different tasks, milestone plans, terminology and acronym explanations, references and reflection
Vincent: for the design document. We have introduction, design countering system, architecture, data design implementation overview design models, test design, deployment and tools and dependency.
Yooni Choi: Okay, it doesn't seem too complicated. After finishing the documents who should submit them. I have 3 interviews next week, so I probably won't. Have enough time to double check the documents and submit them.
Jeffrey Feng: I am pretty flexible in the next week, so I am fine with either way submitting the documents on grade scope should be pretty straightforward.
Vincent: Yeah, I would also want to focus on itc project next week. I cannot write any code without she. so I will probably spend a lot of time in a office or next week.
Vincent: so I will not also be able to submit them.
Yooni Choi: Okay, Jeff, do you want to submit the documents? You can always let us know if you need any help.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, sure. I can do that
Jeffrey Feng: for next week. Jeff's action item will be submitting the plan and design document.
Jeffrey Feng: I will let you guys know when I finish. The submission
Vincent: sounds good chat. Thank you very much for your help. Do you guys have anything? Now you want to discuss this meeting?
Yooni Choi: I think we're good. Everyone seems to have a clear idea of what they are supposed to do next.
Jeffrey Feng: Okay, bye, bye.